[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 y viernes ya finalizamos
semana Rosa Pérez mateu que bueno
tenerla como siempre por acá para abrir
esta revista de prensa con una
publicación en el país que los
periodistas cristianos asegura y Luis de
Vega hacen a voluminiza una entrevista
no exactamente Buenos días Raúl una
entrevista un texto que empieza con la
siguiente descripción dominados por la
penumbra los pasillos del búnker en el
que se ha convertido la sede
presidencial en kiev no desentonan con
el resto del país el complejo está bajo
restricciones energéticas como el resto
de Ucrania porque como comentabas en el
noticiero la guerra los ataques rusos
han afectado un 40% de la
infraestructura energética ucraniana y
respecto al tema que ocupa el titular es
una cita de selensky que dice la anexión
rusa de los territorios ucranianos anula
toda posibilidad de diálogo para
negociar la paz con Putin de lensky
impone una principal dice que los que
Rusia reconozca su error particularmente
si los rusos se retiran y reconocen que
están terriblemente equivocados si es
que esto se puede considerar un error
entonces podemos encontrar un formato
para el diálogo pero si nosotros vamos a
seguir sacrificando miles de Vidas para
que se desocupe nuestro territorio creo
que esto impide el proceso de diálogo
durante años dice que la gota que colmó
el vaso fue la anexión unilateral de
Doña escanes
que en agosto también anunció además su
intención de recuperar crimea un
territorio si cabe todavía más complejo
porque Rusia lonecionó en 2014 los
periodistas dicen una de las amenazas
que planean sobre la resistencia
ucraniana no procede de Moscú sino de
Washington y le preguntan a selenski
precisamente por si está preocupado por
si los republicanos se hacen con la
mayoría de legislativo Este martes tras
las elecciones de medio término porque
distintos representantes hmn
republicanos y han declarado que no
están de acuerdo con mantener el ritmo
de ayuda actual a Ucrania el selens que
dice que no porque la sociedad Al fin y
al cabo estadounidense está del lado de
Ucrania por otro lado los periodistas
dicen el presidente ucraniano se muestra
visiblemente irritado cuando se le
pregunta sobre la Decena de partidos
pero rusos y legalizados por Ucrania en
estos meses de guerra a lo que es que
responde si hay alguien en Bruselas
preocupado por ellos que encuentren
lugar para estos partidos allí y
hablando de Bruselas que pide a Europa
que a isles si cabe todavía más a Rusia
que considera una organización criminal
dice insiste en la idea que ya reiterado
en repetidas ocasiones que Ucrania está
haciendo de escudo para Europa pero que
sin embargo el futuro de Ucrania pasa
inevitablemente por entrar a la Unión
Europea precisamente dice no quiero
decir que sea que tarde o temprano vayas
a suceder esto porque Considero que ya
es tarde Rosa y también con respecto
ayuda internacional Ucrania no como
también lo hemos conversado aquí con
varios analistas evidentemente es un
tema finito porque pues los países
tampoco pueden estar digamos este
mirando sus recursos a otro lugar no
sobre todo en un contexto donde estamos
aportas de una recesión económica
mundial y pues toda la inflación que
evidentemente necesitan los recursos
para trabajar en sus países claro ahora
es una cuestión entre otras cosas
también de comunicación política porque
recordemos que Estados Unidos de hecho
manda ayuda militar a Ucrania desde 2014
no es algo 9 nuevo a raíz de esta
invasión a total sin embargo ahora sí
que se ha incrementado y también se
publicita mucho más bueno vamos a ver
qué va a pasar y vamos a pasar ahora a
otro tema Rosa que comentamos el día de
ayer de ayer porque Twitter ya digamos
empezaría el día de hoy a despedir
formalmente a sus empleados exactamente
ayer mismo y lo más dijo a sus empleados
que hoy recibirían un email
informándoles sobre si hacen parte de
estos a miles de despedidos o no y así
titula
inicia los despidos masivos en Twitter y
por otro lado bloomberg dice Twitter
está demandado por los despidos masivos
de más sin previo aviso Y es que decenas
de trabajadores han impuesto una demanda
colectiva en la corte Federal de San
Francisco porque consideran que Twitter
incumple la ley que establece la ley
federal que establece que una empresa
debe avisar con 60 días de antelación a
sus trabajadores ante una despido masivo
y en junio de hecho trabajadores de
tesla ganaron un caso similar cuando
iban más quiso despedir a un 10% de la
plantilla bueno y hoy también es noticia
Rosa la visita del canciller alemán
en su reunión no polémica con el
presidente chino exactamente Y empezamos
por ver como lo titula el frankfurter
algo maina este medio económico alemán
que lo titula lo destaca más por el lado
de la guerra en Ucrania no dice los
gobiernos de Beijing y Berlín están de
acuerdo en que las de Rusia con armas
nucleares son inaceptables que Alemania
Pide a China que utilice su influencia
sobre Rusia para ponerle a fin a esta
invasión y por otro lado el shorts
insistió no en rechazar la crítica a su
visita el canciller Alemán o el jefe del
ejecutivo alemán dijo que en tiempos de
crisis el diálogo es más importante que
nunca y también en términos económicos
pidió a China que hubiera igualdad en
términos de inversiones recíprocas entre
las empresas de un país y otro y
respecto a los respectivos a territorios
y por otro lado tenemos el people sea
Daily este medio de China que titula por
una con una cita de sí que dice la
visita mejorará el entendimiento mutua y
la confianza entre Alemania y China Rosa
y finalizamos con la portada de la
revista Time exactamente porque la
dedica al controvertido Mundial de
fútbol que tendrá lugar Próximamente en
Qatar y titula así de dangerous game el
juego peligroso con el siguiente texto
miles de trabajadores migrantes han
muerto preparando Qatar para acoger el
mundial en un mundo que se está
sobrecalentando esto es solo el
principio pero hemos querido contraponer
esta portada crítica no con el hecho de
que se celebre el mundial en Qatar con
el hecho de que cuando Time este mismo
año hace unos meses publicó una lista de
las 50 mejores destinaciones para viajar
este 2022 una de ellas era doha Qatar
que describía como el lugar de las
maravillas del mundial de fútbol
Wonders y informaba de que había 100
nuevos hoteles y atracciones construidas
para el mundial y 160 vuelos al día para
desplazar asistentes no a esta
competición y describe el lugar como un
oasis de lujo y excesos
Rosa Pérez mateu Muchísimas gracias como
siempre por la revista de prensa sin
duda este tema polémico del mundial de
Qatar en un país donde Pues están entre
dicho no el respeto también a los
Derechos Humanos por supuesto Gracias
Rosa feliz fin de semana y nos vemos
pronto aquí en directo América